you ever wonder why China fears Indian
respect India why is it that India has a
hundred apps that China has that they
don't allow in India India doesn't allow
Tick Tock to be there America is okay
with it why is India saying no to China
as a form of rejection right so we went
and looked at around 30 different
markers comparing China versus India
when you see some of these numbers
you're going to say no The Edge on this
goes to China The Edge on this goes to
India but eventually you're going to see
this is the one area where India can
come up and maybe just maybe be China
all right so if you give out yet this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
I'm going to show you data like
population age teacher ports airport
we're going to talk about every single
thing but pretty much every single thing
between China and India and some of
these numbers are going to shock you on
who's got yet so let's get right into it
all right let's start from the top
population wise the difference is only a
hundred thousand India just passed up
China here's what it looks like China is
at 1.425 billion 671
000 people while India's 1.425 776
000 barely have a bigger population than
China so the edge there goes to India
average Asia population China 38.4 years
old India 28.7 years old The Edge there
goes to India life expectancy male in
China they live up to 75. in India they
live up to 60 60 Edge goes to China
female in China live up to 81 in India
69 again Edge goes to China that
migration break when it comes down to
China they're actually negative point
one one percent that means people are
leaving but if you look at India they're
actually positive 0.12 percent people
are moving to India Again The Edge there
goes to India size of land China
9.6 million square kilometers India 3.3
million square kilometers China gets the
edge there cost of living if U.S equals
100 where do China and India measure
against that China would be 57.58 India
is 27.24 that's terrible The Edge there
goes to China average income in U.S
dollars China 11 880 India two thousand
one hundred and fifty dollars Again The
Edge goes to China GDP watch this one
here I got to give you this one to go to
1950 1990 then today because there's a
whole story behind this thing in 1950
China's GDP was 100 billion India's was
50 billion China was only twice as big
as India but Watch What Happens 40 years
later in 1990 China has 360 billion
India Caught Up 3 326 billion they're
like this of passing up China but then
something happened China joined the
World Trade Organization look what
happens next today China 18 trillion
dollars India 3 trillion they went from
being pretty much tied to now China is
six times bigger the edge goes to China
roadways 5.2 million kilometers in China
but 6.4 million kilometers in India the
edge here goes to India railroads China
96 000 miles of Railways railroads India
42 000 miles Edge goes to China airports
China has 214 India only has 82 Edge
goes to China major ports this is
important because this is Import and
Export major ports China 34 India 13
Edge China miner ports China 2000 you
ready with India only 205 Edge by 10
times goes to China let's look at
quality of life because if you're
healthy you can work better you don't
have setbacks you can go 12 months
versus somewhere where you're constantly
unhealthy out of a hundred in China 69
is the score and quality of life India
30 The Edge goes to China climate how
the weather is in China 54 score India
62. Believe It or Not The Edge goes to
India internet users in China 1 billion
41 000 in India 613 million Edge goes to
China but this next part is the one that
matters the most broadband internet High
internet speed look at the difference
between China and India China
536 million high-speed internet access
India only 28 million China is 20 times
stronger there obviously the edge goes
to China Health Care System let's look
at how many hospital beds per thousand
China 4.31 beds per thousand India
0.53 that's terrible again Edge goes to
China Dr per thousand China 1.79 India
0.78 Edge goes to China tuberculosis
0.55 percent of people out of 100 in
India 2.1 percent out of 100 that's four
times worse it's a lot of setbacks Edge
goes to China education when it comes on
to students per teacher in China it's 16
to 1. in India 35 to 1. again the edge
here goes to China the next one is to
look at how much Global money is being
invested into their infrastructure as a
percentage of their GDP China 4.8
percent India 1.1 percent Edge goes to
China this next data is insane this next
lead us to look at how much cement they
use in their country ready China used
7.2 billion tons in three years they use
more in two years than America use in
the entire 20th century 100 years that's
China you want to know what India did
just in 2022 355 million tons this is an
area where the edge goes massive to
China next main language spoken in China
81 percent of the people speak Mandarin
in India 57 speak Hindi now here's
what's crazy about it China has 300
different languages but 81 percent all
speak Mandarin which is good because we
can communicate India only has 120
different languages but the one main
language only 57 speak so when I'm doing
business with you and I'm communicating
it's kind of tough again Edge goes to
China next literacy rate China 99 India
75 that's a big difference you know why
because the more educated your people
are the higher quality jobs they can do
to help the infrastructure if China is
99 and India's 74 75 percent The Edge
goes to China but so let me ask you if
you're watching all this is going back
and forth you know on the edge goes to
China and the edge goes to China Patrick
I'm seeking I'm from India Patrick Jamar
screw you you can't be saying stuff like
this totally get it but you know what we
realize China has the edge in what area
it's only one thing if you think about
it it's purely infrastructure let me
explain to you why all right so when it
comes down to ease of doing business
China has consistently ranked higher
than India on the world bank's ease of
doing business index indicating a more
friendly regulatory environment for
businesses China today is ranked 32
India is ranked 62 according to the
World Bank infrastructure China's
Advanced infrastructure in terms of
Transport Logistics and Technologies
more developed compared to India which
makes business operations smoother for
foreign companies manufacturing based
China has positions itself as the
world's Factory attracting investment
from companies from around the globe
seeking to take advantage of his
manufacturing capabilities establish
supply chain and relatively low labor
costs policy environment China opened to
foreign investments earlier and more
comprehensively than India which was
more cautious in its approach to
liberalization just in 2018 Chinese
exports were 2.64 trillion dollars
versus India only being half a trillion
dollars therefore India did not
experience fast economic growth and
poverty rate only drops slightly more
than 10 percent over the last 30 years
so what does all this mean here's what
it looks like if you look at poverty
rate in China from 1990 till today China
went from 99 poverty rate that means
only one percent in China who is doing
okay for themselves to 25 but during
that same period India only dropped
lower poverty rate by only 10 percent
infrastructure by the way I want to give
you a little bit of credit to India
because we have to realize this if you
think about Kobe this is one of the
biggest edges India has over China think
about it during covet what country lost
credibility and Trust around the world
what's the number one country that lost
credibility around the world that's
China it was so bad that Tim Cook
running Apple all these iPhones are
being made out of China gradually is
Shifting that over from there to where
to India why it matters that the world
trusts India more than they do China
purely trust like I don't think they're
going to do deceptive practices and
China doesn't have their credibility
today but India has to move because this
season's not going to last for too long
of the time you have to capitalize on
the season and last but not least to
give credit to India there's a couple
things we do need to give credit to so I
want you to look at this chart from
World economic Forum look how it
Compares China to India you know we keep
talking about the great infrastructure
with China but China is like oh we got
this money build it do you want me to
build it perfectly no no just build it
build the building already hurry up guys
what's going on let's go we got three
months but but sir I'm not building I'm
telling you Bill I gotta hit my deadline
right versus India's like no let's build
it properly so even though they built
infrastructure faster sometimes they
build it so fast that not all this stuff
works well they destroyed rebuild it
again versus India did it right so the
edge if you look at this chart right
here overall quality of infrastructure
blue India yellow China quality roads
India against th quality railroads India
against th quality Port India against th
Quality Air transport in the against the
edge quality electricity Supply India
gets the age overall infrastructure
India guess the age Global
competitiveness index India gets the age
so you know the whole thing between
quality and quantity quality India
quantity China there's an edge last six
points for India to be thinking about
number one figure out a way to increase
your skilled Workforce you have to focus
on that through education number two
ease of doing business they can address
this this is purely Law and Order
regulation you can deregulate certain
areas that's slowing down it's very very
annoying when regulation is high for
business owners the government controls
this if they want to they can deregulate
many parts of the business number three
infrastructure development we've already
talked about this they know what areas
to focus on number four investment
incentives India could consider offering
tax breaks subsidies and other
incentives to companies both domestic
and foreign to say you know what I'm
willing to move there number five invest
into research and development the one
thing that we have to give credit to
India India has won the best schools in
the world IIT it competes with MIT I've
spoken at IIT trust me when you there's
so many different comparison between
those two schools a lot of people MIT so
they're investing they're gradually
producing all these Engineers they just
got to do a little bit more of it
political stability and Foreign
Relations look there's there's some
people that hate Maori there's some
people like Modi I like Modi I like the
fact that he's been able to do what he's
done to India recently and I like the
fact a part of India you can't push them
around like they're not afraid of China
can you imagine they're like yeah we'll
do business with you a hundred apps of
yours not gonna be allowed here you're
not going to bully us around you can
bully America you can bully this guy you
can you ain't gonna bully us you got to
respect the part of what India is doing
but if India can figure out a way to
attract more apples more people that
want to start doing business with India
and saying hey you can trust us here's
what we're all about I think I can
really start competing with China 10 20
years later but we'll see if you want
this whole spreadsheet that we just
talked about today comparing China and
India to get a text toward India to
310-340-1132 we're going to text you
back the PDF and to print it out and
look at it for yourself again text the
word India to
310-3401132 or subscribe to the news
better below and if you got value from
this video you want to watch another one
especially those of you guys that are
Indian that don't like the fact that I
give so much love to China
I did a video talking about China's
number one problem if you've not seen it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
foreign